das interesse daran was geht hier so
adriani und heute gibt es ein mädchen
sky wars und wir spielen das ganze nicht
gewöhnlich sondern wir machen es cases
change die abonnenten von meinem bruder
von sg wurde kennen das vielleicht und
zwar wir spielen das einfach und der
eine darf den anderen dumme dinge sagen
die ihr tun muss ja okay also leute
kleine info ich habe sprinten immer auf
shift max hat sprint auf steuerung und
tauscht als erstes mal eine steuerung
jetzt hier werden die ja ein hotel
erstmalig sprinten auf shift und nicken
auf der normale mensch das ist das
normale möchte deshalb mit dummheit ist
es normal dass sind wir wieder wie
derselbe karte und muss ich die
steuerung ist so beibehalten eigentlich
ja so habe ich das gegenteil sei deshalb
eine oder maximal keinen jackpot an
aber es geht abwärts
dann hätte ich auch so gemacht aber nein
sonst seien aber klar aber jetzt geht's
los
liga was ist denn los
ja da bin ich wieder freunde und schon
wieder die ich verliere trotzdem jeder
runde taktik so was muss ich jetzt
bisher alles machen so du musst schon an
der steuerung wechseln displays darf ich
aber jetzt jetzt darfst du das ist
wieder eine macht es mir hier alles gut
spielen wie die bockhorster dankeschön
haye aber vielleicht passiert gleich war
ich hoffe mich hey hoffentlich kann
keine firma spss du darfst diese person
nicht schlagen nie die alte darf sie ab
welche diese person die da hinter der
die da die abschrankungen erleben die
dass die da oben hast du auch schon
bedienen die auf den tour bin ich wieder
hier jetzt kommt das schon okay jetzt
uns verbrannt einfach nein es ist gemein
ist heruntergefallen
ich glaube ja aus respekt es gehe ich
selbst wird ein schwert weg hey danke
dass ich noch einen tab oder ist das
mein schwert das ist auch weg
das wird noch besser gleich geahnt dass
keiner das ist noch okay ich würde mal
sagen während du dieses wie viele leute
sind auch eine runde 44
dann wäre erstmal den vierten eine
belohnung darf wie ein schwert dafür
treffen ist ja doch so lange bei sich
seit das es erlaubt das ist eine optisch
hat den nur dass das nicht macht klar
pass auf wenn dein leben
er brennt gewisser prenzlauer berg jetzt
bevor den typen angreift geht erst mal
eine schöne ladung druck
max hat sicher seine pcs druckluft
freigekauft das um seine pcs werten
lüften
jetzt testen wir einfach mal ob das auch
für ein menschliches gesicht geschaut wo
ist ihr gegner ist jetzt an und ich geb
dir einfach druckluft ich habe gewonnen
als ob die golden harp wir wollten im
herz oder holt gold in den hell aber
warte mal wurde ich ist auch man sollte
das nicht auf der kss
und so glaube ich wir können müsste es
sagen ja erstmal auf vor jetzt irgendein
rüstungsteilen anziehst große lugano
fragst du darfst es hieß es internet
bewegen
es gibt eine rückkehr es gibt dort kommt
ein halo
gibt es jetzt darf sie nicht anziehen
also du das schon kämpfen hey ludwig
rüstung anziehen da hab ich jetzt schon
anziehen
ich muss dich grad an dann habe ich
rüssel anziehen bitte die wird jetzt
also keine lust hast du gesehen
wichtiger weggekommen als alter sehr
schön okay also das nicht schaden
danke bei die weißt du was herr scholz
es gibt keinen bercow jungen ist sehr
schön logo hättest du das jetzt anziehen
wie vielleicht leben noch
die leute leben noch höher führen dazu
dass noch ein gegner hart fanfiction
kann direkt mit michalsky setzt sie mal
kein staat an banken macht das lieber
nicht kann der gerne mal wieder zwei
spieler alter zwei spieler echt ok geht
es los leute dunk luft im kampf
druckluft ja klar hat er wird erstens
nur kurz später für augen
das ist auch mein gesicht sehen das
ganze nicht mehr ausgewogen politisch
und schüttelt es nicht an es kommt da
dieses zeug raus wenn du dich in zukunft
erlauben
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen auch wenn
es kurz war
aber jetzt wo es oft auf mich ein wenig
jetzt kurz weg fragen kann vielleicht